hi guys it's silver at again and yes I
am finally playing rollicking to like to
be honest this week I haven't done
anything because I got so many requests
to play this game and I was like yeah
why not it's my it's kind of my
childhood with a Mexican one and Freddy
fish that is and I was just thinking
yeah I might as well try it I might as
well install it again and see what I can
come up with so I installed it and I
didn't do anything else this week I was
just playing Roy goon to non-stop
playing scenarios making scenarios doing
all that kind of stuff so then I figured
you know what
I can actually do this let's play
because right now I'm too hooked to this
game to actually play rollick scream 3
for serious right now so that's why I
figured I'm going to do this rock screen
2 let's play so I took the liberty and
designed a little scenario kind of thing
for me I mean it's just some Dodge
Porter thing which of course it's
flatland so that's a lot easier but I
got a good excuse I mean it's Holland
it's a flat country and I just made a
little town and the little river kind of
thing right here and I'm kind of
thinking of just defining the park into
3 or 4 different areas with different
themes too bad I can take too many
themes so I got the Roman theme the
Chinese / Japanese Asian kind of theme
maybe a mine theme somewhere and that'll
be about it I suppose though I could I
could also go for Asia on this and have
an Indonesian themed area Japanese and
the Chinese area or make the entire
thing Japanese or have the Roman part I
don't know I don't get to do maybe I
could do like Asian culture thing like
ancient European cultures and the
ancient Asian cultures I have no idea
I'm just going to start on this and see
where this whole thing takes me so I'm
just going to start on a generic
entrance for my park and maybe make some
Main Street kind of thing I'm not
totally sure what I'm going to do with
this but I'll see I suppose
right so I suppose that this should be
good for now because I don't think I can
do anything else yet because that's
going to take too much time and yeah I
don't want to start on the themed areas
just yet and I built this little
entrance temple kind of thing for the
Roman area I was kind of planning to do
here but it looks kind of crappy so I'm
probably going to remove that to be
honest it really looks weird but this
entrance Plaza looks pretty decent
though I have to admit I really have to
get back into this game
I mean before ever before anybody starts
like whining or whatever you want to do
I am NOT using custom scenery nope
I'm not doing that also I'm using
hypercam - so that's kind of cool
but yeah it's nostalgia basically
because if I want to really build a
detailed park with nice scenery and
details basically and good looking
things and all that I'm going to play
roller screen 3 like there's no no other
reason for me to play role execute -
other than the fact that it's a lot
easier to build the idea to make the
idea that you have of a theme park to
turn that into reality that's basically
the thinks it's it takes a lot less time
to build stuff and yeah that's the
number one reason well the number two
reason of course that I'd play Rolex
akin to because the number one reason is
nostalgia at least for me I just love
being able to play roles going to again
and those those graphics you know these
graphics they're just they're instant -
pure happiness of nostalgia for me but
it starts raining so I better head out
so see you next time